we're living with some some grown sons
aren't you yes who am i living with yeah
interesting yes I have grown sons I have
a 20 year old in a sixty and a half year
old okay and and these what's it like
having living away
I don't do you know what it's like well
I don't know what it's like I have I
have a daughter who's 14 and I have a
son who is 12 and so I don't really know
what it's like to have big guys around
the house you know I'm saying yeah
that's a lot of saltines I'm not sure
why it's just a lot of saltines and
orangie you know just like all over the
floor I wake up in the morning and it's
just like you know a horror story of
that's happened in middle of the night
I'm not quite sure what they're up to
it's amazing to me what I've noticed
with my son what kids can put into their
bodies and they're still fine like
you're saying that your your kids are
just living off of saltines and Orangina
yes yet they're still growing yeah step
cells are still you know my surprise he
texted me like five minutes ago and he
said he was busy eating red vines and I
was like oh my god dye number three
you're gonna die any minute stop stop
now
first of all when you wave the cane
around like that it really has an
old-lady vibe no red light yeah it seems
it seems to me like it's a little I mean
first of all you're lucky if that's your
problem you've got these teenage kids
and they're like they were out till 11
o'clock at night and they came home and
they stank of red vines no they're great
they're great and the teacher
oh they Giada since you're kind of like
you like a little strawberry gene little
strawberry ginger going there huh
yeah audience of 300 one person thinks
that's okay
do they like being gingers they don't
get when I was at I didn't like it when
I was a kid I wanted to have jet black
hair like Elvis or McGarrett on Hawaii
five-o I wanted a jet black hair and
then when I had orange hair it bothered
me you know I think they're into it
actually I think they like it maybe it's
getting cool again
maybe someone back maybe someone has
made it cool again that was a joke I
think they think you mean Prince Harry
yeah
do you play what do you do with them you
play video games with them like how do
you connect with with teenagers I think
I have played video games in the past
but you know once they got past Guitar
Hero they lost me that was it I never I
never moved past it I mean you didn't
mean you liked Guitar Hero you did
I loved Guitar Hero and then they
wouldn't play with me anymore so I see
myself why did they stop which is really
sad why do they stop playing guitar with
you I guess they just grew out of it and
I never did right do you still play
guitar hero I don't because they changed
the you know they changed guitar hero so
it's like it's it's not the same yeah
it's not the same this is a weird that
you're giving a review of Guitar Hero
once you go after Ms Pac Man now it just
doesn't grab me anymore
were you good at it would you really
like on the solo yeah oh yeah every now
and then when I would do it I would
every now and then catch my reflection
and notice that I was jamming out and I
would feel really sad about myself
it's a good thing I was alone
you